[Music]  if you listen carefully enough  the past whispers to you  we're here to see alice dumbledore  that would be my brother  the world as we know it is coming undone  grindelwald's pulling it apart with hate  if we're to defeat him you'll have to  trust me  [Music]  this is the team that's going to take  down the most dangerous wizard in over a  century  a major zoologist his indispensable  assistant  wizard descended from a very old family  a school teacher  [Music]  and  a muggle dumbledore said i give you  something  are you kidding me right now who  wouldn't like our chances  [Music]  i have to save the world are we  [Music]  things are not quite what they appear  [Music]  swivel but delicately i'm swiveling  right you're traveling  [Music]  what is this place the room we require  [Music]  correct three points to hufflepuff  [Music]  very dangerous forgotten wrong hands  mess you up where did you guess it  i got for christmas  [Music]